so und ich glaube das schloss ist ja
nicht einfach kurz alles nach rechts
wisse was geht damit ich so viele
menschen wie möglich bekommen
er hat mir ein super light gegeben
irgendwie junge und schreibt hey kleinen
anna danke für den match die 99 gleich
wie vorher ich so meine konstant und
warum gehst du nicht daran wie viel die
nacht
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video aber
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut
heute nach sehr langer zeit mal wieder
aus dieser wunderschönen perspektive und
zwar habe ich mir gedacht alex du kannst
auch eigentlich wieder entspannteres
video machen
ein schön von zu hause weil die anderen
sind halt immer deutlich aufwendiger und
der eine oder andere von euch fragt sich
jetzt wahrscheinlich ist zu hell
man sieht es ich habe meine haare nicht
gemacht und ich habe gerade weil 20
zentimeter langen bart rasiert also ich
finde ich sie wieder aus wie 16
obwohl ich sonst auch eigentlich
höchstens aus sowie 17 oder 18 so weit
bin ich auch noch nicht auf jeden fall
hat es einen ganz bestimmten grund jetzt
ist es wieder zu dunkel alter rassen
geht mir so und jetzt sondern bist du
bleibt das ist das problem wenn man
nicht mit soft boxen arbeitet auf jeden
fall wurden mir in letzter zeit sehr auf
videos vorgeschlagen das lag daran weil
ich es einmal selber geguckt habe also
da ging es darum dass leute einfach mal
gesagt haben passt auf ich stelle mal
ein bild von ihr mit diesem geld filter
instagram nicht auf instagram auf kinder
rein und schaue mir die reaktion sind ob
ich da ein paar heiße matches abstauben
kann und ich habe mich wirklich gefragt
alter also wenn ich da jemanden sehen
das ist doch offensichtlich wenn man
diesen snapshot geld filter benutzt dass
das halt kein echtes mädchen ist so also
ich würde das glaube ich erkennen aber
nicht vergessen es finden sich immer
blöde also der plan heute ist das jetzt
erst mal meistens pick aufzunehmen mit
diesem snapshot girl filter also darum
geht sollte wir machen heute ein tender
experiment das ist das erste kinder
experiment auf meinem kanal die sind ja
ein bisschen inso eigentlich so gerade
oder sind im trend
und ich bin wirklich mal gespannt wann
muss ja sagen so jungs die sind auf
jeden fall zum großen teil wenn sie sich
bei kinder anmelden auch kraß unterwegs
also da wird beschreibt was das zeug
hält so auf jeden fall versuchen jetzt
mal kurz am fenster mit natürlichem
licht ein extrem nettes foto
hinzukriegen mit diesem geld filter halt
also hier bin ich sage heute ich mache
mir noch eins irgendwie im liegen da
weil das ist glaube ich ein bisschen
besser okay leute also ich muss sagen
das war echt anstrengend hat auch echt
lange gedauert weil wenn ich mich ja
selber zum beispiel da sehe denke ich
mir okay das
doch kein schwein auch soweit diesen
haaren hier ich bleibe euch das super
gerne mal hier ein ich weiß nicht also
ich glaube ich muss das noch mal kurz
durch photoshop ziehen damit dass ein
bisschen authentischer rüberkommt also
ich bin immer noch nicht ganz überzeugt
man kann da eigentlich auch nicht
wirklich was rausholen das ist jetzt das
bild so wie es jetzt gerade aussieht und
ich würde sagen da wird versuchen wir
das einfach mal ich werde natürlich auch
noch so ein body foto von mir hinzufügen
also das hier ist das erste bild und
dann einfach noch so ein bild wenn man
das gesicht nicht sieht versteht und
wenn da jemand drauf anspringt dann tut
es mir natürlich gleich weil ich ihn ja
an sich verarsche aber wenn man auf so
was reinfällt dann ist man doch
irgendwie selber schuld oder mein
vorname ist anna warum nicht obwohl ward
war 2001 wäre 17 noch ne ja okay ich
mache mal 17 weil älter wird mir auch
keiner abnehmen oder altersbeschränkung
du musst mindestens 18 jahre alt sein um
kinder benutzen zu können keine sorge
weil bald schreibst du mit obst und
jetzt leute ich sitze jetzt hier die
ganze zeit schon wegen dieser verfügten
altersbeschränkung das könnt ihr mir
doch nicht erzählen krieg die nämlich
jetzt nicht mehr raus ich habe das schon
gelöscht wollte ich mit facebook
anmelden geht nicht das heißt ich
brauche jetzt irgend eine andere nummer
mit der ich mich da verifizieren kann
leute was geht ein bisschen zeit ist
jetzt schon vergangen ich hab es
hinbekommen mich anzumelden die war eine
andere nummer
also ich hab jetzt schon mein profil
hier angelegt ich zeige es euch hier
gerne mal ich habe mich wieder genannt
wenn jetzt sogar schon 19 jahre alt
kunsthochschule für medien köln habe ich
noch nie gehört aber sowas gibt machen
wir mal altersgruppe bis 80 bis 100 plus
heftig wie gesagt dies eine foto habe
ich schon hochgeladen
jetzt fügen wir noch ein weiteres hinzu
ich finde das hier zum beispiel passt
richtig gut also leute ich habe jetzt
mal alles eingestellt also hier diese
beiden fotos dass ein habe ich noch
hochgeladen kann man ja da sehen das ist
so ein spiegel safety mit blick von den
haaren hat also auf jeden fall perfekt
gepasst
dann habe ich hier noch hingeschrieben
das bin ich einer 19 auf der suche nach
freunden und dates instagram auf anfrage
es ist ganz ganz wichtig glaube ich weil
die meisten leute dort haben als
instagram verknüpft das kann ich ja
schlecht machen job bezeichnen studentin
wohnort nordrhein-westfalen köln
und ja das war es auch schon so und ich
glaube das schloss ist wenn ich jetzt
einfach kurz alles nach rechts wischen
was geht damit ich so viele menschen wie
möglich bekommen und ich glaube immer
noch nicht dass ich mit diesem foto hier
gegen den spiegel oder warschau
ach komm doch ist das ist doch jetzt
verschwindet ich habe gerade drei mal
also dass das mich ja so auch leute ich
habe gerade drei mal nach rechts
gewischt und habe zwei dates nähe zwei
matches sorry wenn das damals so gewesen
wäre als ich dasselbe hatte also so riel
hatte aber das war zu heftig gewesen vor
allem ich habe das gerade mal zehn
minuten eingerichtet buben noch match
noch mit die 2 doch einfach alles nach
rechts oder das kann mir doch keiner
erzählen boom neuer match neuer manager
das geht ja wie am fließband boom zu
locken match irgendwo bei mir läuft ja
so heftig die junge dort gibt's doch gar
nicht alter da komme ich ja absolut ich
hoffe die leute ich melde mich wenn ich
die erste steht an frage habt ja guck
mal hier kann man das sehen ich habe
einfach schon acht matches ist
unglaublich schnell leute ich kann nicht
aufhören aufzunehmen das ist sowas von
krank ich kriege einfach nur ich habe 28
matches und ich habe gerade mal fünf
minuten angefangen zu zweit oder was
geht ab und hier kommt ein match nach
dem nächsten reihen
das hätte ich niemals gedacht komm hier
könnt ihr das sehen jetzt habe ich sogar
schon insgesamt 32 matches und drei
nachrichten anfragen lässt simon also
ich würde mich gerne für ein date
bewerben nagel alles klar wo kommst du
denn her
ich warte mal sind das einfach
vielleicht irgendwie so fade bots also
ich wollte wirklich gerade den glauben
an die menschheit bzw haben die
männlichen menschheit an die männliche
menschheit ja schon sieben jets ich bin
jetzt erst mal ich muss erst mal eine
pause hey leute diese schätzen zu genial
drin
der hat mir der hat mir ein super light
gegeben
junge junge und schreibt hey kleinen
anna danke für den match über all das
aus was geht leute was geht dann ein
kleines update wir haben schon ziemlich
spät ich bin gerade wieder gekommen
wollte noch mal wenn kinder account
reinschauen ich habe auch zwischendurch
mal angeschaut und ungelogen ich bin
wirklich nicht klar gekommen ich hatte
fast 300 matches 99 sich leicht auf den
standort wir haben so viele menschen
geschrieben und was ist wenn du mir
haben extrem viele ältere männer
geschrieben und ich idiot habe ich daran
gedacht dass eventuell ja das
zugesperrt werden könnte und ja das ist
jetzt passiert dein konto wurde gesperrt
ist ein bisschen scheiße ich möchte
jetzt natürlich da auch niemanden
vorführen oder so ich dir ja eh alles
aber was mir dann leute geschrieben
haben ich wirklich absolut nicht klar
gekommen ich hab mir jetzt noch mal
neuen account eingerichtet genau gleich
aufgebaut und dann schaue ich mal ob ich
morgen euch noch alter fast 64
das ist ich habe schon wieder 64 likes
und ich verstehe auch absolut jedes
mädchen wird da keinen bock drauf hat
was diese männer teilweise schreiben da
das also das schockt mich wirklich ja
ich wusste dass es schlimm ist aber das
ist so schlimm ist kommen wir heute also
mir tut's leid wegen der schlechten
qualität gerade aber das ist ja auch
egal ich habe mir diesen account vor
fünf minuten erstellt und ich habe jetzt
schon die 99 like sie vor ich super hier
kunst dran dass wir jetzt hier gar nicht
ein bildschirm aufnehmen
ihr könnt es ja sehen und ich denke das
ist so heftig mehr dazu gibt's morgen
ich muss jetzt erstmal schlafen bis
morgen leute was geht ab da sind wir
wieder
wir haben den nächsten morgen und ich
starte direkt mal mit einer negativen
nachricht in den tag und zwar wurde
meint inder account schon wieder
gelöscht hatte ich denke halt mal es
liegt daran weil mich natürlich
also nicht wundern wenn das jetzt nicht
so wäre sehr viele leute melden die halt
direkt sind okay das ist der snapshot
filter aber mich hat es extrem gewundert
dass mir nicht eine person geschrieben
hat ja wo willst du wenn wir das hier
verarschen das ist doch einfach nur das
netz statt filter wahrscheinlich weil
diese person dann mich gar nicht nach
rechts weiter also nicht licon trotzdem
ich bin ja nicht dumm man lernt aus
fehlern ich habe gestern noch mit ein
paar leuten geschrieben und einige
screenshots gemacht videos gemacht und
davon wollte ich jetzt ein paar noch
zeigen
erstmal muss ich sagen ich habe es ja
gestern schon gesagt dass ich mich sehr
darüber gewundert habe oder was heißt
gewundert so ich find's ok ich hab mich
da ja 18 beziehungsweise 19 gemacht und
wir haben sehr sehr viele ältere männer
also ich hab ja bis 100 angegeben
ein super light gegeben also das ist
halt dieses da musst du so extrem nach
oben 2 und dass da noch bestätigen also
das kann ich aus versehen passieren oder
so und wenn dann halt auch noch
geschrieben so ja
hey ich bin viel älter als du findest du
das denn gar nicht schlimm und so und
ich habe mir dieses profil aber
irgendwie 57 uni lehrer hat er in seinem
profil stehen und dadurch wirklich junge
junge irgendwann durch gefälschte ja das
habe ich kurz gemacht das ist ein video
da sieht man alle schätzt die ich
gestern abend noch bekommen haben
innerhalb von was weiß ich zehn minuten
oder so und das ist wirklich extrem cars
ich hatte schon wieder über 50 matches
wahrscheinlich heute morgen über 100
keine ahnung ich fange mit diesem chat
an das ist ein typ der war irgendwie 47
der hat mir geschrieben hallo anna
vielen dank für die blumen tolle augen
hast du daran gebe ich hänge ja also die
da hat wirklich gedacht dass ich die
augen die dara sieht also das verstehe
ich verstehe es einfach nicht leute erst
mal einen spaß findet ihr auf so was
einfallen ich habe wirklich gedacht okay
das wird sehr sehr schwierig dass da
leute drauf wenn man also mich ist das
komplett unverständlich so danke wo bist
du zu hause was machst du später noch
liegt schon im bett aber bin gerade erst
heim gekommen
so klingt ja gespannt jetzt ja bis eben
auf arbeit na gut mit bier in der linken
hand und dann habe ich so gedacht sehr
gut kommen jetzt jetzt geht es rauf aufs
ganze und in der rechten also in der
rechten hand stift computer mein schritt
der war auch ich wie lehrer oder das ist
auch keine ahnung ich hab das glaub ich
ja ich will ich will das gar nicht
gefallen weil ich möchte auch niemanden
ansatzweise bloßstellen dass er sich
hier wieder erkennen und sich dann
stimmt oder so keine ahnung oder der
hier das war martin der war über 50
neuen suche hier fan freundschaft und
was sich so ergibt wohnen in bonn bin
mobil besuchten sono und älter wie du
wenn das alles kein problem ist kann
sich gerne melden und das hier war der
krasseste suche nur noch was lockere
also entweder kommt zu mir oder tschüss
dann habe ich so eine nummer geschickt
diese sonne sex hotline ist denn er sei
worauf stehst du dein whatsapp nummer
wollte ich so hab' keine blösse und
warum gehst du nicht daran wie viel die
nach ich hab noch mehr jets wenn ihr
sagt ließ sie auch noch vor gibt noch
nach oben da macht man auch im zweiten
paar bei 10.000 likes ich brauche
einfach 10.000 raus weil ich kann mir
gut vorstellen dass ihr euch das wünsche
ich muss jetzt mal wirklich sagen das
video oder dieses video jetzt zu drehen
das waren 1 heftig wichtige erfahrung
glaube ich für mich einfach um halt mal
so zu sehen wie wie krank viele männer
sind oder was heißt krank kann kann ich
sie nicht mehr sagen aber wie
aufdringlich manche männer sind auch
ältere männer egal ob die person jetzt
wahrscheinlich wäre es auch wenn ich
jetzt 17 gewesen wäre wäre es
wahrscheinlich nicht anders gewesen also
hätte ich mich dort als jetzt den jäger
angemeldet geht ja nicht mehr also ich
kann absolut verstehen weil manche
frauen so von diesem tender und so
genervt sind und sich denken alter das
mache ich mir nie wieder also leute ich
glaube ich habe in dieser kurzen zeit in
der die accounts existiert haben
bestimmt über 200 matches gehabt
was weiß ich wie viele leute diesen
account geleitet haben natürlich dann
legen wir auch gemeldet und das hätte
ich wirklich nie nie niemals gedacht das
war's mit dem video wenn ihr sagt
manchmal ein paar kippen doch nach oben
haut rein technischer instagram account
ob da ist alex wie zschau